hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to
administer a medication via the buckle
route so let's get started what is the
buckle route well the word buckle
actually comes from a latin word buca
which means cheek so we're giving this
medication in between the cheek and the
gum where it's going to be absorbed into
the mucous membrane then into the
bloodstream now in nursing we don't give
a lot of medications this way but there
are some groups of medications that are
administered the buccal route such as
certain types of opioid pain medications
some smoking cessation products
nitroglycerin which can also be
administered sublinguals so always make
sure you're reading that medication
label and also anti-seizure medications
and some forms of hormone therapy now
let me demonstrate how to administer a
medication via the buckle route first
you want to perform the medication rides
then hand hygiene and dawn gloves next
you'll want to use a tongue blade to
assess the mouth you're going to be
looking at the teeth and the gums making
sure that they're clean and if they're
not clean this is a good time to provide
mouth care then assess the mouth
especially the mucous membranes for any
breakdown or swords because you don't
want to administer a medication on these
areas now once you've done your
assessment you're ready to administer
the medication and depending on what
type of medication you're giving always
refer to the manufacturer's guidelines
about where they want you to place the
medication because some are specific so
here i'm going to use the tongue blade
to help me assist opening the mouth and
i'm going to place this tablet on the
maxillary arch above the second molar
and i'm going to make sure it's staying
in this pouch area here now i want to
release the tongue blade and allow the
cheek to close and i am going to just
take my finger and just slightly rub the
area on the outside of the mouth where i
place it just to keep the tablet in
place and help it dissolve and doing
this depends on the manufacturer's
guidelines next i'm going to doff my
gloves and perform hand hygiene then i'm
going to document and when you document
you want to be specific about where you
place the medication so the next nurse
knows where you gave it last in case
they have to rotate the site for the
next dose for example you could write
that you went at the maxillary arch
above the left second molar now let me
give you some quick tips that you want
to remember whenever you are
administering a medication via this
route first you want to make sure that
you're familiar with the medication
label because every medication is
different some of these medications they
dissolve fairly quickly in this route
while others may take several hours so
you want to make sure that you're
reading that label so you can get
familiar with how soon your patient can
eat or drink once you have administered
this medication also you want to make
sure whenever you're handling these
medications that your gloves are dry
because they're activated whenever they
come into contact with a moist
environment and lastly let's say that
your patient needs multiple doses of
this medication and this particular
medication requires that you alternate
sites for each dose we always want to
look back at the documentation of the
other nurse and see where they placed it
and then alternate the placement okay so
that wraps up this demonstration on how
to administer a medication via the
buckle route and if you'd like to watch
more nursing skill videos you can access
the link in the youtube description
below